hi it's michelle vlad muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and cosmetic
chemist and today we're going to go
through my teenage skin care routine yes
a lot of the products were horrifying if
you like nerding out about the science
behind beauty products click like
subscribe and the notification bell i'm
turning 35 this year which means i grew
up in the 2000s the 2000s were a time of
britney flared jeans butterfly clips and
some really cringy skincare despite some
really cringe moments i think overall in
hindsight it was actually quite a nice
time
you had a bit more breathing room
between apocalyptic events
so here is what i look like in the 2000s
i went through a lot of regrettable
years when i didn't have a fringe i sort
of was channeling
the middle-aged accountant vibe
you can also tell it was like the height
of my trichotillomania i was doing a lot
of hair pulling and you can see the hair
regrowth is
a bit warped so what skin care was
teenage michelle using
firstly i was using the avon
invigorating scrub my dad bought this
when i started getting pimples and it's
kind of exactly what you'd expect a
clueless dad to buy this was bright blue
it had scrubbing particles in it which
were shaped like shards like they were
literally triangles
it was mentholated to death
and yeah it was fresh to death it felt
like you were sandpapering your face and
then dunking your face in a bucket of
ice water and this was kind of what we
assumed acne care should have been at
the time this was before the gospel of
paula of paula's choice our lord and
savior really took hold this was even
before google took hold we were
searching things on like yahoo search
alta vista and ask g's we weren't going
to find polar i'm pretty confident this
was way worse than sinai's apricot scrub
to no one's surprise my skin did not
like this i actually remember the skin
on my nose going hard and stiff and
cracking and i remember trying to peel
off the flakes with a pair of tweezers
and that was not good i ended up with
just a constantly scabby nose this was
dehydrating as hell and i have
dehydration prone skin
so yeah this was not a happy time you
cannot successfully treat acne by just
scrubbing it and drying it out harsh
treatments will usually just make acne
worse because one of the contributing
factors to acne is inflammation now the
next step in my teenage skin care
journey was clean and clear's three-step
oil control pack at the time clean and
clear had this massive campaign that was
targeting teenagers they would stick
these little sample bottle packs to the
front of teenage music magazines i got a
bunch of different sets from this
magazine i used to buy called tv hits
and i actually remember buying this
exact one it had five on the cover my
best friend at the time was obsessed
with this boy band 5 and she made me
give her the centerfold
we're not friends anymore for
unrelated reasons so looking this up
based on the ingredients it looks like
the exact same formulas as i was using
20 years ago are still available now the
packaging is exactly the same it doesn't
like they're sold in the us or the uk
anymore maybe they're just shunting the
leftovers to us australians because no
one cares about us okay the cleanser
this ingredient list looks nothing like
anything else i've seen in a really long
time i think the way it's working is
they've got free fatty acids and
triethynolamine which is a base
and by mixing that together they
basically make soap i remember this
being really foamy and for these soaps
of factors to foam well it'd have to be
somewhere near ph 8 or 9. it also has
methyl isothiazolinone as a preservative
this is mi and it's a pretty common
allergen it's only allowed in wash-off
products these days and you don't really
see it in face products that much
anymore it is reasonably common in
shampoos and conditioners my skin is
generally pretty robust but this
particular ingredient and its cousin mci
both make me really itchy
and i wonder if i was actually allergic
to this product at the time and i just
didn't know i do remember this being
pretty stripping and we all thought back
then that stripping is good type means
clean and a lot of people still think
this it's not true if you feel tight
after cleansing usually this means that
the proteins in your skin have changed
their shape they're denatured and since
these proteins are an essential part of
your skin barrier that means that your
skin barrier is probably leaky it's
losing water and it's letting irritants
in now the toner this was a really blue
alcoholic toner this is basically
paula's nightmare toner these days
toners are a lot better they're not just
dehydrating alcohol-laden products
anymore except apparently this one it's
a pretty simple formula it's got alcohol
and salicylic acid it's also got
glycerin 26 which is emollient it's sort
of like a less effective version of
glycerin it's also got alan tone and
panthenol which are soothing and
moisturizing ingredients which i don't
know if they're gonna help given
everything else in this formula this was
super watery so you had to apply it with
a cotton ball and i remember it stung so
much and the assumption was if it hurts
it works now the moisturizer this
ingredient list actually looks pretty
similar to a lot of moisturizers that we
have on the market now and it's actually
kind of nice seeing all these parabens
in there i remember this being fine i
remember i didn't really use it that
much because i had oily skin and acne
and the myth is if you have oily skin
and acne you don't need a moisturizer
i need a moisturizer i wonder if i would
have had an easier time getting into
skincare if this had glycerin in it it
does have propylene glycol as the second
ingredient this is a humectant but it's
nowhere near as hydrating as glycerin my
skin is really dehydration prone and
yeah this moisturizer did not convince
me that my skin needed moisturizer if i
was redesigning this moisturizer i'd
replace the propylene glycol with
glycerin and i would add sun protection
to this i think it doesn't have sun
protection because it has 0.5 salicylic
acid and in the us that would make it a
drug and i don't think you're allowed to
have sunscreen and salicylic acid in the
one product we already have salicylic
acid in the toner anyway so i think
getting rid of that and putting in sun
protection would be really good as an
introduction to teenage skin care i also
used clean and clear blotting papers and
these were also attached to the front of
a magazine these actually look pretty
much the same as the ones i used when i
was a teenager i don't think they've
really changed these and
yeah i think that's actually because
they were pretty good they're these
light blue sheets that you press down on
your face they soak up oil and you can
see the blue plastic go clear it's very
satisfying it's a nice way of getting
rid of excess oil without irritating
your skin
these are made of plastic though and
these days i use paper ones that i get
from an asian supermarket and they seem
to soak up more oil as well as being a
bit more environmentally friendly the
next step up was when i actually bought
my own products instead of getting them
off the front of a magazine
i was using cedarfield gentle skin
cleanser and nivea visage cleansing gel
i think these two products are where i
got my hate of cleansing over the sink
from the cedar fill was a gel product
that didn't foam so this one you could
either put it on your face and wash it
off or you could actually put it on your
face and then wipe it off with a damp
cloth since my skin was oily i kind of
felt like this just didn't do much and i
don't remember using it more than a
couple times i do remember the bottle
sitting in my bathroom for years so i
think really the problem here was that
this just didn't match my skin type
now the nivea cleansing gel some not
very well formulated cleansers do this
thing where they stick onto your hand
and they don't really foam up so you'll
put it in your hand you'll try to firm
it up you'll wash your face you'll rinse
off your face and then after all of that
you'll still have like
a dollop of gel stuck to the middle of
your hand even these days there are a
few cleansers i've used that still do
this one is the inky salicylic acid
cleanser i don't know why i kept on
buying this even though it was such a
pain to use i think it might have just
been the cheapest cleanser from the
supermarket but this was actually quite
hydrating it didn't strip my skin
it was just a little bit annoying to use
so onto the product that every teenager
ends up using benzoyl peroxide my first
benzoyl peroxide product was benzac 10
cream because i decided to be a cheap
boss and i saw this stuff online about
how you should be using 2.5 but i
figured 10 divided by 4 if i just dilute
that i will end up with 2.5
of course the first day i got lazy and
instead of diluting it i just sort of
went i'll just put less on my face and i
put it all over my face i went to uni
and then in the middle of the day
someone was like michelle
are you sunburned
so basically the benzoyl peroxide was
really irritating and i think it made my
skin all so sensitive to the sun and so
i just sort of had this beet red face
that just started in the middle of the
day to make things worse benzaak also
has micro sponge technology so it's got
like little white bits in it and i had
tiny little white flecks all over my
face as well it was a disaster so after
trying to make that work for a few days
i think i abandoned it and i just went
off and ordered 2.5 benzoyl peroxide
from acne.org acne.org is a website
started by a guy who had bad acne
and he made his own products because he
just found them so difficult to find and
2.5 benzoyl peroxide is like the
cornerstone product so his version was
really good it was pretty cheap it had a
decent texture and the only problem was
that it took a while to ship to me which
was why i started with the benzack this
worked quite well but it did sort of dry
the crap out of my face benzoyl peroxide
is really good at reacting with dyes and
breaking them up and that causes things
to bleach these days there are lots of
benzoyl peroxide washes available and i
would go with one of them instead
because you can wash it off and so less
of it ends up on your towels and on your
clothes and on your pillowcase so that
takes me to uni and the end of my
teenage years i still hadn't worked out
a skincare routine by that point
and honestly i didn't really get
anywhere with my skincare until i was
around 21 or 22 and even then it took me
a few years to get the hang of how to
give myself a skincare routine so it
took me till my mid to late 20s to
really understand my skin and be able to
predict which products would actually
work well for it my excuse is that we
didn't really have the resources that we
do now we didn't have skin care on
youtube the only place you could really
find good information was the pooler's
choice website also notice the distinct
lack of sunscreen in my routine i didn't
really start trying to wear it till my
mid-20s and even then it took me a few
years to get consistent with wearing it
every day so i hope you enjoyed this
throwback episode let me know if you
recognize any of these products or if
you use them and if not what were the
iconic products that you used in your
teenage years i'm going to post a
routine that i wish i had when i was a
teenager soon so subscribe and click the
notification bell for that you can also
follow me on instagram and tick tock and
check out my blog for more see you next
time for more science